Greg who do you have here uh just some
little thing I found on the street
this is my first pet that I've ever had
his name's Gus his name is Gus check him
out isn't he great he's got a nice
little jacket oh he's only eight weeks
old how much does he weigh he weighs
about uh you know that's kind of
personal
[Laughter]
yeah I think he weighs about six and a
half
pounds
eats like a pig farts like a don't shame
him just like his owner just like me
loves wine what has been something that
you didn't anticipate the wild satanic
screaming of a puppy in the middle of
the night when you have a puppy and you
want to create them they didn't tell you
about the sounds they make it's on
otherworldly and you don't know what to
do you just have to ignore him and then
it gets better but what about all the
good stuff like all those good feelings
that you get I thought I'd get some good
feelings don't like us
Gus this is your moment
no he's like I need more food just don't
throw up on me that's Jesse's you know
job okay I'm glad we got to meet your
emotional support dog Greg I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now